So when your users access your web apps
they don't type in your IP address.
They put in a name like www.example.net,
a web address with a hostname in it.
The way that your hostname gets
translated into an IP address
is through the Domain Name System,
or DNS.
DNS is a worldwide distributed
directory of network information.
It stores a wide variety of records but
the best known kind of DNS
record is the A record.
A for address, which maps a name like
www.example.net to an IPv4 address.
Client programs such as web browsers
look up these records in order to find
the address of a web site or
another service.
As the creator of a website you
need to set up DNS records for
it so that users can access it by name.
Usually that will involve registering
the domain with a registrar and
pointing the DNS records at
the web servers IP addresses so
that users will be able to reach them.
A little later in this lesson you'll
have a chance to do exactly that.
A DNS turns out to be really
important for websites.
If your DNS goes down, your site
can't be reached by most users.
A number of big sites
including Google and
Microsoft have had embarrassing outages
caused by their DNS records expiring.
DNS domains are also used as part
of the security mechanisms for
HTTP, including SSL encryption and
cookie privacy.
The DNS client code which
is called the resolver,
is built into every operating system.
Programs such as NC or ping, or
web browsers can just use it.
To test out DNS,
we'll use a couple of handy shell
utilities called Host and Dig.